facebook gründer mark zuckerberg hat
elon musk angeworfen es geht um unser
letztes video ihnen macht waren ja vor
den gefahren von künstlicher intelligenz
kurs ki und da findet mark zuckerberg
gar nicht so gut denn macht fordert
regulierung für savas ein graus wenn er
will mit facebook gerade den rückstand
bei ki auf eine baldige regulierung
können sie ihnen da einen strich durch
die rechnung machen jetzt den blick vom
science fiction herzlich willkommen
jetzt geht es zur sache markt wasserburg
fossilen musk freie entwicklung von
künstlicher intelligenz bertels
kontrolle und regulierung es geht um die
gefahren die von ki ausgehen ob sie
existieren oder ob sie nur in gespinsten
den letzten video hatten wir ja darüber
berichtet maske waren eindringlich vor
ki und durch die straßen marodierenden
robotern die alles töten was sich ihnen
in den weg stellt künstliche intelligenz
ist ein fundamentales risiko für die
existenz der menschlichen zivilisation
so wie es autounfälle flugzeugabsturz zu
drogen oder schlechtes essen nie sein
werden ich habe zugang zu modernsten
künstliche intelligenz die es gibt und
ich glaube die leute sollten besorgt
darüber sein so machte in einem
interview auf der national governors
versammlung in den usa za camberg wirft
ihn jetzt vor negativ und damit
verantwortungslos zu sein
er ist jedenfalls optimistisch in sachen
kann er leute die diese
weltuntergangsszenarien beschwören nicht
verstehen ein frontalangriff auf markt
und auch die bemühungen bei ki sehr
vorsichtig zu sein und die gefahren
stets im auge zu behalten macht konter
der augenblicklich und ließ auf twitter
verlauten und gibt ebenso eine breite
auswahl comeback ab er habe mit
zuckerberg gesprochen und ein sehr
eingeschränktes verständnis der materie
festgestellt mit anderen worten
zuckerberg hat keine ahnung sollte das
allerdings zutreffen wäre es gefährlich
den wasserburgs arbeitet intensiv an der
entwicklung von ki bei facebook hat er
ein team aus internationalen
spitzenkräften zusammengestellt und
google vorsprung aufzuholen und wer wie
doppelt zum einen hat die google-tochter
sieht meint mit der künstlichen
intelligenz avantgarde den besten
spieler der welt geschlagen
zum anderen hat google mit google brain
ein neuronales netz mit die burning
entwickelt das zum beispiel seit letztem
jahr den youtube algorithmus selbst
programmiert das macht google grant
täglich und das für jeden nutzer
individuell jeden tag empfiehlt google
brain jedem nutzer individuell videos
dafür wird die bosch und surgery
durchsucht und mit anderen nutzern
abgeglichen bei übereinstimmung werden
videos empfohlen
die anderen nutzer mit ähnlichen
interessen gefallen jeden tag wird
google brainbows schlauer und findet
immer besser videos dies empfehlen kann
schon heute sind wir also von k abhängig
und wie entscheidet für uns welche
videos und als nächstes empfohlen werden
vielleicht siehst du dieses video auch
gerade weil es google brain für dich
ausgesucht hat schon ein bisschen
gespenstisch was noch gespenstischer ist
ki übernimmt auch die schlechten
eigenschaften von nutzern so ist sie
rassistisch wie in einer
forschungsarbeit der künstlich
university in den usa festgestellt wurde
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
auf den studienleiter einigen khalid
khan hatten herausgefunden dass die
künstliche intelligenz an gewohnheiten
von menschen übernimmt künftig ergänzt
wird ja in form von programm mit
unendlich viel daten gefüttert und dazu
gehören auch eine unmenge an texten so
lernt die software sowie anhand von
texten wörter und wächst sie in
beziehung zueinander irgendwann weitere
beispiel dass mann und frau
in welchem verhältnis zueinander stehen
die youtuber und youtube
das problem am bibeltexten ist dass sie
von menschen geschrieben wurden und die
haben vorurteile
das forscherteam hat jetzt das gelernte
von globi überprüfen es dabei darauf
gestoßen dass die software so auch
vorurteile übernommen hatte typische
vornamen von afrika aus afroamerikanern
waren für die software eher unangenehm
und typischerweise eher angenehm die
software hatte alle vorurteile aus den
eingespeisten texten übernommen also
schon jetzt schnell ki eine wirkliche
gefahr zahl noch ganz anders macht es
befürchtet aber es zeigt dass die
wirklich kontrolliert werden muss
zuckerberg ist hier wirklich etwas sagen
wir optimistisch wieder streit weiter
geht darüber halte ich euch hierbei ging
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
videos zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf wie locker hier geht
es weiter mit künstliche intelligenz ist
menschlich da geht es um rassistische ki
und was die forscher und forscherinnen
genau herausgefunden haben dass wirklich
etwas erschreckend also unbedingt
anschauen also drauf klicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran